Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we're going to talk about a task that
humans are remarkably good at, but learning
algorithms mostly flounder.
And that is creating 3D geometry by looking
at a 2D color image.
In video games and animation films, this is
a scenario that comes up very often - if we
need a new weapon model in the game, we typically
give the artist a photo, who will sit down
with a 3D modeler program, and spends a few
hours sculpting a similar 3D geometry.
And I will quickly note that our binocular
vision is not entirely necessary to make this
happen.
We can look at 2D images all day long and
still have a good idea about the shape of
an airplane, even with one eye closed.
We had previous episodes on this problem,
and the verdict was that that the results
with previous techniques are great, but not
very detailed.
Mathematicians like to say that this algorithm
has a cubic complexity or cubic scaling, which
means that if we wish to increase the resolution
of the 3D model just a tiny bit, we have wait
not a tiny bit longer, but significantly longer.
And the cubic part means that this tradeoff
becomes unbearable even for moderately high
resolutions.
This paper offers a technique to break through
this limitation.
This new technique still uses a learning algorithm
to predict the geometry, but it creates these
3D models hierarchically.
This means that it starts out approximating
the coarse geometry of the output, and restarts
the process by adding more and more fine details
to it.
The geometry becomes more and more refined
over several steps.
Now, this refinement doesn't just work unless
we have a carefully designed algorithm around
it.
The refinement happens by using additional
information in each step from the created
model.
Namely, we imagine our predicted 3D geometry
as a collection of small blocks, and each
block is classified as either free space,
occupied space, or as a surface.
After this classification happened, we have
the possibility to focus our efforts on refining
the surface of the model, leading to a significant
improvement in the execution time of the algorithm.
As a result, we get 3D models that are of
higher quality than the ones offered by previous
techniques.
The outputs are still not super high resolution,
but they capture a fair number of surface
detail.
And you know the drill, research is a process,
and every paper is a stepping stone.
And this is one of those stepping stones that
can potentially save many hours of work for
3D artists in the industry.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!